so you're dragging a circle around on
the left that is like your heads up
display it's just a little circle made
in like a Microsoft Paint window on the
right you have stable diffusion creating
beautiful real-time images what we're
really seeing happen here which I think
is just fascinating is the creativity
explosion goes up because a lot of
people don't have the ability to
describe what exactly what they're
looking for and then iterate it in ways
and then you see here the cre the
creativity of the model when I'm on the
left here my intent was a moon with a
mountain in the background but when I
move it over to the right I get this
person because it drew a silhouette of a
person it thought your drawing was a
person's face so I think this is like a
1.0 product I give it a B I want to see
multimodal input here and I want to see
more participatory AI I want the AI
talking to me